merci
[Musique]
donc c'est une boîte pleine d'ordinateurs et
les ordinateurs sont immergés dans une huile inerte
donc une huile qui n'endommage pas les
ordinateurs bien au contraire ça aide en fait
les ordinateurs il n'y a pas de ventilateurs donc
ça les protège en fait
et  ce qui se passe, c'est l'huile les
ordinateurs dans l'huile les ordinateurs chauffent
l'
huile l'huile puis
s'écoule à travers ce tuyau de l'
autre côté de la salle des machines
Ça va coule dans un échangeur de chaleur et dans
cet échangeur de chaleur l'huile chaude
rencontre le  l'eau froide de la piscine
[Musique]
Échangeur Elite
étranger
[Musique]
le coût du gaz était au plus haut nous
avons réduit la température de notre piscine d'un
demi-degré seulement
mais pas plus car les clients
s'habituent à une certaine température de la piscine
donc nous avons  été assez durement touché par cette
augmentation du coût du gaz pendant l'hiver,
mais j'espère que l'hiver prochain,
une très grande partie de nos coûts de chauffage
proviendra de la technologie Deep Green
qui est en fait un
chauffage gratuit pour nous en tant qu'opérateur, ce qui
devrait faire une différence significative  l'
année prochaine dans l'hiver à venir
[Musique]
étrangère